in symbol we'd Park there's murderer
foot and we've got the gameplay from
this new point-and-click adventure to
prove it if you want to see more
coverage of the game including our
review check out gamespot com and
subscribe to our channel on YouTube
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I fly halfway around the world and an
odd note is waiting for me in my hotel
room it says to come to the bridge down
by the river this looks like the place I
could really go for some Venus little
after the long walk out here
are you a victim of the inferior
American social support system yeah yeah
I need some whiskey I have to go i'm
sorry i could not offer you a drink
to as a traitor to thimble we'd Park 1.7
I wonder if i can use this rock to put
out the light it is it is a rock
there i have completed step 3 of the
note now for step four
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
so tell me again why you're here I was
assigned to the case by the Home Office
in Albuquerque there is no home office
in Albuquerque it's neat to know look I
like working a case alone I especially
don't need some junior agent messing up
my investigation especially some junior
agent that thinks I don't know there
isn't a home office in Albuquerque so
stay out of my way take a lot of notes
sit back and learn and I'll wrap up this
case and we can both get the hell out of
here your reputation certainly precedes
you agent ray I'll take that as a
compliment agent Reyes period car would
was intended I'm sure it was let's
photograph the victim and head into town
to talk to the local sheriff the body is
starting to pixelate body starting to
pixelate this is going to be a long
night
there's no film in the camera
[Music]
it's an empty whiskey bottle
appears to be a male approximately 40
years old looks like he's been in the
water for 24 hours you can tell by the
pixelation around the nose and neck
let's see here there's no wallet in his
pocket but I found a card possibly a key
card from a hotel it's covered by the
underbrush but as an old abandoned
chainsaw fool me once shame on me fool
me twice that doesn't seem to work it's
an old abandoned chainsaw definitely not
the murder weapon no missing body parts
metal sounds like someone in the sewer
is playing the violin but the trail ends
here at this huge rock wall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's an instant camera but there's no
film in it it's a cell phone
[Music]
it's an interesting camera but there's
no film it there's no film in the camera
it's already open there's no cap on it
the camera is out of film no thanks
[Music]
trestle trail dissemble we park 1.7
miles
[Music]
I think we better take a photo of that
body before it pixel eights any further
[Music]
look sign to me
it's a sample package of polaroid film
it only contains one photo sure I'll
carry your crap it's an instant camera
but there's no film in it
smile now we can head into town and find
the local sheriff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well blaster from mucus phlegm games
never heard of it
[Music]
it's a circus flyer with a crazy-looking
clown on it pretty good makeup though
signals are very strong tonight why are
you dressed like a giant pigeon where
the page and brothers plumbing I'm Beth
that's my sister Emily hi there but
remember signals are very strong tonight
what signals the signals signals are
very strong tonight why brothers if your
sisters dad was expecting to have sons
when he was too cheap to have the van
repainted sir is wrong with it till he's
dead oh shut up Emily signals are very
strong tonight yes you already think
that but what signals haha I'm just
screwing with you tonight deserted Road
me and a giant pigeon costume it was too
good to pass up but the signals are
strong tonight very strong this is
really odd should I save my game I
wouldn't worry about it the game was
expertly designed to have no dead ends
or guess it'd still be scary and have a
sense of tension you can feel safe
exploring whatever you want but I'd
watch out for the signals it can be very
strong and disrupt the power grid
I think I've had enough of you I need to
find the sheriff and solve a murder nice
talking to you too click click click
click click click click no need Appert
are outside the war
[Music]
from a six pack you're supposed to cut
them up before tossing them save
wildlife it's an empty soda bottle
[Music]
[Music]
you
wait for me
the
Willie's watchin violin repair shop
symbol weed County's most exclusive
watch and violin repair we were bare
watches and violins for the rich or
famous howdy I'm the nimble we park
Sheriff I don't remember calling the
federer knows that's what you are feds
hard to miss the government issues suits
I'm agent ray and this is my partner
nice to meet you agent URI nose looks
like you heard about our little murderer
Reno well by the bridge huh there is
nothing little about murder sir ignore
him he's new no sense in wasting
everyone's time Reno this cutscene is
certainly get long and it's only gonna
get longer let's find the corner and get
you on your way for wrestling starts at
eight I hope he's talking about on TV
the coroner is waiting for you in his
office come see me when you're done I
apologize arena for all the lights being
off and we don't stay open as long as
you city slicker Reno do at night even
for a murder especially for murder does
that make no sense are we authorized to
shoot people arenas
[Music]
howdy who I'm the thimble we'd Park
coroner welcome to the future who
so these are the latest in
crime-fighting computers made by pillow
tronic sync this is all probably pretty
advanced to be even for the bedrooms oh
do enlighten us oh I love your sarcastic
humor who agent rate it's not humor yeah
there you go again we're interested in
any healthier computers can give us they
look marvelous yes happy to explain
they're so happy to explain the who yeah
you might want to take notes already on
it tell us about the blood from 3000
this is the blood Tron 3000 put two
bloody objects in and it will match the
blood type printing out a report 20 tell
us about the face drawn three thousand
that based on three housing door as i
like to call it let me guess the face
arena haha no that's what sheriff calls
it yahoo city wolke hulan crack me up
just insert two pictures of an
individual and it will verify a positive
match tell us about the finger Tron 3000
writer reno the finger trod 3,000 insert
a fingerprint registry of known
criminals and a fingerprint from the
murder weapon on fingerprint tape and it
will do a matcha who fascinating stuff I
think we've heard enough this is all
very impressive sir this should cut
hours of our investigation and go see
the sheriff in his office for a full
explanation of the amazing a restaurant
3000 I have some paperwork to do with
who oh yeah almost forgot Aziz Tron
machines aren't fully voice-activated so
if
information just talk to them it's like
we're living in the futuristic year of
2017 I hate this town let's investigate
these prawn machines then go see the
sheriff and get out of here it's a hotel
key card from the dead man
[Music]
it's a good photo of the body it's a
hotel key card from the dead man it only
works on the room doors in the hotel
I'm not putting my finger in there I'm
not putting my finger and I'm not
putting my finger in there insert two
photos of an individual in the face
traum three thousand will verify a
positive match and print out a report
full a voice-activated stop reading you
start talking that doesn't seem to work
insert a blood sample taken from a body
along with a bloody object the blood
drawn 3000 will confirm a positive match
and issue a report full a
voice-activated stop reading and start
talking is an empty can of Crockfords
tuna heads the good parts still has that
fishy tuna head smell it's famous for I
need to stay focused
[Music]
I can't reach that hello again agent URI
knows hopefully the coroner filled in on
our state-of-the-art torino computers
[Music]
you I mean the corner sets something
about the restaurant yeah the arrest Ron
3000 the last step in a fully
computerized the Reno arrest the final
link in the chain of a guaranteed
conviction of Reno every detail of Reno
analyzed and verified by a computer
moving on right sorry a Reno I get
carried away sometimes this is the big
bad boy or reno you've been hearing
about the arrest Ron 3000 just feed
three reports from other Tron machines
into this and it issues a one hundred
percent to Reno valid arrest warrant
yeah these machines are the reason we
need only one law enforcement officer a
Reno Chuck said the computers will soon
put us all out of work allowing for a
full life of luxury
[Music]
should we investigate Chuck as a suspect
sadly Chuck passed away a few days ago
there was a big service out at the
cemetery arena so the entire town showed
up which isn't surprising for the hero
of thimble weed County it will talk more
about Chuck later I need to run a Reno
and check on a disturbance call out of
the old circus probably that stupid
clownery no again looks like we need to
go talk to the rest of the weirdos that
live in this town we should split up it
will be faster you cooling your heels
and the local diner would also make
things go faster if we follow agency
question and protocol this shouldn't
take long just don't mess anything up I
want to get out of here as fast as
possible agreed
[Music]